[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild ja ich habe 11 Jahre knastweg ich
habe 13 gehabt ich war von Anfang an
Erziehungs da und so scheiß alles und
ich scheiß mein
Leben ich ganz im Ernst war ein was ich
da abgespielt das es weder in der
polizeitaktischen Führung noch unter
Journalisten in Medien dass man eben
Freihaus ein so dramatisches Ereignis
geliefert bekommen hat zwei Geiselnehmer
sitzen im Auto mit Geiseln und lassen zu
dass Zivilisten Passanten und eben auch
Journalisten quasi an das Auto
rankommen herzlich willkommen zu einer
Doppelfolge von Tatort Deutschland ich
bin merko Kasimir und ich bin Stefan
Netzeband wir erinnern diesmal an die
geiselname von Gladbeck im im Sommer
1988 damals starben nicht nur drei
Menschen damals versagte die Polizei auf
ganzer Linie und der Journalismus in
Deutschland überschritt gleich eine
ganze Reihe roter Linien über diesen
Sündenfall gibt es schon jede Menge
Serien und auch sehr gute Podcast wir
packen dazu ein paar Links in die Show
nototes wir besprechen heute mit unseren
chefreportern Peter hell und Frank
Schneider was das Land gelernt hat aus
diesem Drama was vielleicht auch die
Bildzeitung gelernt hat aber dazu müssen
wir natürlich erstmal in die Zeit
zurückreisen 16 August 1988 uh 7:55 Uhr
die mehrfach vorbestraften kriminellen
Hans-jürgen Rösner und Dieter digowski
dringen kurz vor der schalteröffnung in
die gladbeäcker Filiale der Deutschen
Bank in die schweächatter Straße ein sie
bedrohen das Personal und erbeuten 120
000 Mark noch während sich die
bewaffneten Räuber im Schalterraum
befinden hat ein benachbarter Arzt die
Polizei
gerufen um 8:4 Uhr das Gebäude und die
Zugänge zur Bank sind so geschnitten
dass die Täter ihren Fluchtweg nicht
einsehen können als die goofski und
Rösner mit ihrer Beute die Bank
verlassen entdecken sie ein Polizeiauto
und drehen sofort wieder um sie nehmen
zwei Bankangestellte als Geiseln
anschließend fordern Sie einen
Fluchtwagen Handschellen und löse Geld
schon zu diesem frühen Zeitpunkt wird
der Polizeieinsatz öffentlich bekannt
der damals noch junge Fernsehsender RTL
plus sucht die Nummer der Filiale raus
ruft dort an und führt ein Interview
Reporter ist ein gewisser Hans Meiser
wer sind sie denn bitte sehoh der
Bankräuber bitte was der Bankräuber sie
sind der Bankräuber ja können Sie mir
sagen welche Forderung sie über die
300000 MA hinaus stellen was für
Fluchtwagen wollen Sie denn haben das
die 3000
marnenn wozu brauchen sie ein
Handschellen das heißt sie wollen ihre
Geisel nicht freilassen wenn Sie die
Forderung erfüllt haben zunächst nicht
wir wollen sie mitehmen wo wollen sie
den
hinfahren sagen gut man kann sie ja mit
Hubschraubern
verfolgen in Gladbeck wird in der Folge
stundenlang verhandelt bis die Polizei
den Forderungen schließlich nachgibt
gegen
Uhr am Abend verlassen die Gängster mit
ihren zwei Geiseln das Gelände an der
schweächhatterstraße mit einem weißen
Audi darin hat die Polizei Peilsender
versteckt doch die Geiselnehmer
verhalten sich ganz anders als man
erwarten könnte Rösner und diggowski
Gurken mit den Bankangestellten Andrea
Blecker und Reinhold alles auf der
Rückbank quer durch glattbeck besorgen
sich an einem Imbis Proviant und
aufputschabletten der Marke vesparxs an
einer Apotheke danach versuchen Sie an
ein anderes Fluchtauto zu kommen kommen
denn die Verbrecher ahen dass der Audi
verwanzt ist der erste Versuch nämlich
das Auto eines beliebigen kneipengastes
in Gladbeck zu erpressen schlägt viel
wenig später entwenden die Täter aber
erfolgreich einen Wagen an einer
Spielhalle aber offenbar sind Rösner und
digowski noch nicht zufrieden und wollen
erneut das Auto wechseln der ebenerst
erbeutete schwarze bMW hat schon mehr
als 200.000 km runter und beschleunigt
nur unwillig und nachdem sich die Medien
schon am frühen Morgen zum ersten Mal in
diesem Drama von ihrer schlechten Seite
gezeigt haben versagt am Abend die
Polizei an einer Tankstelle begegnet
Rösner einem völlig ortsfremden
kripoeamten der dort allein hin beordert
worden war obwohl der Polizist auch noch
einen Hund dabei hat überwältigt Rösner
ihn und nimmt ihm Waffe und Funkgerät ab
immerhin die nächste Finte der Polizei
gelingt auf die Tanke rollt nämlich ein
blauer Mercedes Rößner bedroht den
Fahrer mit der Waffe und nimmt den Wagen
an sich tatsächlich aber war genau das
gewollt der Fahrer war ein Polizist der
Wagen auch wieder verwanzt mit dem neuen
Auto dreht das Verbrecher Duo noch eine
Runde durch Gladbeck und holt rösners
Freundin Marion löblich ab dann geht es
auf die
Autobahn ohne große Vorfälle machen die
Täter und ihre Geiseln eine nächtliche
Rast in der Nähe von M frühstücken in
Hagen und fahren dann in Richtung Bremen
weil Marion löblich dort Verwandschaft
hat Jahre später nämlich 2018 erhielten
wir von Bild Zugang zu einem
ursprünglich vertraulichen Dokument eine
Wanze im Wagen zeichnet die Gespräche
zwischen den Geiselnehmern und den
Bankangestellten
[Musik]
auf
oder
[Musik]
nein kann überhaup
kein die Aufnahme ist kaum verständlich
zunächst tauschen die Insassen des
Wagens Banalitäten aus über den BMW über
seine Bezeichnung über den Führerschein
der Bankangestellten andreaer geht es um
Sonnenbrillen die digowski gerade
gekauft hat hört man auch Türen klappern
schließlich sagt digowski über
geiselname und den Einsatz von Waffen
wir brauchen uns keine Vorwürfe zu
machen in Bremen fegesag besuchen Rösner
und seine Freundin eine boutik um dort
Kleidung zu kaufen es ist jetzt früher
Abend am 17 August
1988 die Polizei geht davon aus dass die
Geiseln sowieso bald freigelassen werden
und verzichtet auf einen Zugriff
wie bitter muss man sagen denn jetzt
wird es erst richtig übel im Bremer
Ortsteil Huckelriede bringen Rößner und
diggowski gegen 19 Uhr einen Bus der
Linie 53 der Bremer Straßenbahn AG mit
32 Fahrgästen in ihre Gewalt die Polizei
hält sich fern stellt nicht mal einen
Ansprechpartner Kameraleute sind näher
am Bus als irgendein Beamter stattdessen
übernimmt ein Fotograf die
Geiselnehmer und so gibt röner eine Art
Pressekonferenz die abends sogar in der
Tagesschau läuft mE nicht dass nicht
besser ist aufzugeben aufgeben auf
keinen
Fall ich kann konkret sagen wie dann
abläuft dann Knall drin und V mein
Kumpel brandgefährlich ne
und letzte ist
dann ja ich habe 11 Jahre knastwg ich
habe 13 gehabt ich war von Anfang an
erzieh alles ne und äh ich scheiß auf
mein Leben und me ich ganz im Ernst ja
aber die anderen die
unschuldigen kann nichts
fen schon allein diese Szenen in Bremen
sind unfassbar und verändert die Polizei
anschließend nachhaltig bildchefreporter
Frank Schneider da steht ein einzelner
Polizist in ganz normalem sommerhemd und
der Dienstmütze auf der Kreuzung und
regelt ein bisschen den Verkehr und er
fährt ein Junge mit einem Fahrrad an den
Bus heran inem die Geiselnehmer sitzen
mit den Geiseln die Sie gerade frisch in
den Bus genommen haben weil den Bus eben
auch keiner geschützt hat und es zeigt
wie absurd die Situation am Ende war die
Polizei hat damals offenbar das Gefühl
gehabt wir müssen die einfach nur in
Ruhe lassen irgendwann hauen die schon
ab lassen die Geiseln los und dann wird
schon irgendwie alles gut und genau das
war ein fataler Fehler die Polizei hat
aber absolut daraus gelernt und ich wage
wirklich zu sagen so etwas wie
Gladbecker Geiseldrama wäre heute in
Deutschland nicht mehr möglich die
geiselname ist inzwischen
nachrichtenthema Nummer 1 in Deutschland
wie hier in der Sendung buten und binnen
von Radio
Bremen inzwischen wissen wir dass die
Geiselnehmer die Sache sozusagen noch
verschlimmert haben sie haben offenbar
das gebe ich mal mit aller Vorsicht
weiter weil die Polizei uns auch darum
gebeten hat Rücksicht behalten zu lassen
weil die Geisel ja nach wie vor in Hand
der Geiselnehmer sind sie haben offenbar
einen Bus in Bremen gekidnappt oder
gekarpert mit mehreren Geiseln und jetzt
auch einen Polizisten dazu als Geisel
genommen und wir haben mitbekommen dass
auf einer Straße wohl eine Geisel
genommen worden ist das ist aber
unsicher zu diesem Zeitpunkt hätte man
mit den Geiselnehmern vielleicht noch
verhandeln können z.B darüber ob sie
doch wieder Geiseln freilassen und mit
einem PKW weiterfahren aber es ist ja
kein Polizist vor Ort so klagt Rößner
auch gegenüber
Reportern ja bis jetzt ist ja noch keine
eingetroffen da die Polizei ist zu feige
zu kommen äh nee die sind so harte Jungs
da ihre sonderereinsatzkommando was
alles haben
Werbung so Mirko hier ist jetzt mal ein
Buchtipp angesagt oh das ist eine sehr
gute Idee ich suche nämlich noch
Weihnachtsgeschenke ich auch mein lieber
und ich bin passenderweise auf eine
coole krimmy Reihe gestoßen od jetzt
machst du mich aber neugierig na sag mal
an ich schreib gleich mal mit also alle
Märchen Enden gut alle Märchen Enden nee
Stopp das ist nicht der Titel aber was
würdest du denn zu diesem Satz sagen
alle Enden gut na ja den halte ich eher
für ein Gerücht das stimmt doch gar
nicht dass alle Märchen gut enden genau
das ist eine Lüge und da sind wir beim
Titel Rotkäppchen lügt heißt das Buch
und mit dieser Lüge beginnt der Auftakt
einer Thriller Trilogie von bestzeller
Autor Elias Haller der kommt aus Moment
Moment Moment warte warte von dem habe
ich gehört der ist Polizist oder und der
kommt aus meiner alten Heimat Sachsen er
kommt aus Chemnitz glaube ich und er hat
Bücher geschrieben über einen Kommissar
namens Donner Erik Donner genau sehr gut
du bist gut Mirko Haller arbeitet seit
20 Jahren als Polizist und jetzt gibt es
eine Reihe mit der Sonderermittlerin
Nora rotmann vom Landeskriminalamt in
Berlin die stößt auf einen
Korruptionsverdacht rund um den früheren
LKA Präsidenten und dann bricht die
Hölle los wie ein blutdürstiger Wolf
zieht ein Killer durch die Hauptstadt er
fügt seinen Opfern größtmögliche
Schmerzen zu dabei inszeniert er seine
eigenen abartigen märchenversion von
Rotkäppchen denn Rotkäppchen haben wir
ja schon festgestellt am Anfang
Rotkäppchen hat gelogen he Stefan das
klingt wirklich sehr spannend und nach
einer guten Inspiration für Tatort
Deutschland das finde ich auch also
Fälle innerhalb der Polizei sollten wir
mal nach gucken hier noch mal zum
Mitschreiben Rotkäppchen lügt der Auftag
zur grimmtrilogie von Elias Haller ist
am 10 Oktober rausgekommen und wenn euer
Interesse jetzt geweckt ist holt euch
das Buch gerne bei Amazon oder klickt
einfach auf den Link in unseren Show
nototes Werbung
Ende nachdem sie fünf Businsassen
freigelassen haben fahren digowski
Rösner und löblich im Bus mit den
anderen 27 Geiseln auf die A1 an der
Raststätte grundbergsee lassen Sie die
beiden Bankangestellten im Austausch
gegen zwei Journalisten frei auf der
gleichen Raststätte leistet sich die
Polizei die nächste Fehlentscheidung
diesmal mit tödlichem Ausgang ohne
Absprache mit der Einsatzleitung nehmen
zwei Beamte Marion löblich fest als
diese auf das Klo geht als seine
Freundin auch nach mehreren Minuten
nicht zurückkehrt brüllt Rösner laut
herum
wahnsinuskmen der
Frau
dies
Rösner fordert dass löblich sofort
zurückkommt sonst werde eine Geisel
erschossen aber jetzt geht wirklich
alles schief die Beamten waren mit ihr
ja schon losgefahren jetzt müssen sie
umdrehen und dann der Schlüssel der
Handschellen bricht ab alles dauert und
noch vor dem Verstreichen des
eigentlichen Ultimatums schießt
dietowski dem 14-jährigen
italieneemuele
der seine neunjährige Schwester schützen
wollte in den
Kopf die Bremer Einsatzleitung hatte
nicht einmal einen Rettungswagen in den
Bereich geschickt aber diese Schlamperei
ist nur noch das Tüpfelchen auf dem i in
die todesstatistik reit sich an diesem
Abend noch der Polizeibeamte Ingo Hagen
ein der zur Raststätte grundbergsee
beordert wurde um das Geschehen zu
dokumentieren er verunglückt bei einem
Zusammenstoß mit einem LKW der Bus mit
den drei Geiselnehmern samt Geiseln
fährt unterdessen Richtung
Holland dort ringt die Polizei den
Geiselnehmern immerhin die Freilassung
von zwei Frauen und drei Kindern ab
Rösner und diggowski ernennen den
Busfahrer Paul mikolitschak zu so etwas
wie ihr Mittelsmann für die Verhandlung
mit der Polizei sie wollen erneut freies
Geleit und einen als Fluchtwagen damit
sie den Bus stehen lassen können die
Geiselnehmer das muss man dazu sagen die
sind mittlerweile völlig übernächtigt
alkoholisiert und zittrig von all den
Aufputschmitteln die sich eingeworfen
haben sie wollen Ihr Gepäck vom Bus in
den bereitgestellten BMW tragen und
weisen einige der Geiseln an sich als
Schutz und sichtmauer aufzustellen beim
Hantieren mit einer Tüte voller
kohaflaschen drückt röner aus Versehen
seine
Pistole chaos bricht aus der Schuss
streift löblichs Bein die aufschreit du
Esel hast mich getroffen die
holländischen Polizisten eröffnen das
Feuer weil sie denken dass Geiseln
getötet werden Busfahrer mikolitchak
erleidet einen Streifschuss an der Hand
einige der Geiseln Rennen in den Wald
nach und nach aber beruhigt sich die
Situation dann tatsächlich doch wieder
die niederländischen Beamten stellen das
Feuer ein die Wunden von löblich und
Busfahrer mikolitschak werden notdürftig
versorgt Rösner und Degowski wollen mit
dem Pkw zurück nach Deutschland und nur
noch zwei Geiseln
mitnehmen Tag 2 der unfassbaren
Geiselnahme von Gladbeck geht zu ende zu
keinem Zeitpunkt hat die Polizei
Anstalten gemacht die Lage unter
Kontrolle zu bekommen schon in dieser
Nacht muss jedem klar sein so kann
Polizeiarbeit in Deutschland unmöglich
weitergehen nie wieder dürfen
Geiselnehmer wie ein Geist des kranker
Wanderzirkus quer durch das Land oder in
Nachbarstaaten Reisen Frank Schneider
das entscheidende dabei ist bei den
neuen Strategien es wäre nie mehr
möglich dass man Geiselnehmer so fahren
lässt wie in Gladbeck das heißt es ist
ganz klare Maßgabe die geiselname wird
vor Ort beendet sie wird nicht mehr
dynamisch sie bleibt statisch sie bleibt
in der Bank und dort wird sie beendet es
gibt nur eine ganz minimale Ausnahme
wenn jetzt z.B Täter was wir uns nicht
vorstellen wollen aber im Rahmen sagen
mal der terroristischen Bedrohung die
wir ja haben natürlich auch möglich wäre
wenn die jetzt alle 2 Minuten jemanden
erschießen wenn sie jetzt nicht
rausgelassen werden aus der Bank oder
das Auto nicht bekommen und die haben
100 Geiseln dann kann die Polizei
natürlich nicht zugucken wie die
nacheinander 100 Leute erschießen aber
dann gäbe es wahrscheinlich auch einen
sogenannten notzugriff auch das die
Spezialeinheiten wären vor Ort und
würden sofort zugreifen und würden dann
eben auch in der Gefahr dass es weitere
Tote gibt aber den den Einsatz einfach
beenden die würden einfach sagen wir
müssen diese Täter jetzt bekämpfen wir
müssen sie jetzt kampfunfähig im
schlimmsten Fall Fall e müssen wir sie
auch durch den finalen Rettungsschuss
töten aber das wäre heute so absolut
nicht mehr denkbar wie es damals war man
gibt den eine Geldtasche und lässt sie
dann munter mit Geiseln wegfahren und
was dann in dem in Deutschland passiert
ist weiß man ja Silke Bischof und Ines
feutle Wissen in dieser Nacht nicht was
ihnen noch in deutschland droht sie sind
die beiden Geiseln die das
verbrechertrio für die Fahrt zurück nach
Nordrhein-Westfalen ausgewählt hat hätte
man das Drama von diesem Zeitpunkt aus
noch glimpflich beenden können und wie
würde so ein Fall heute im Zeitalter von
Smartphones und Livestreams wohl
ablaufen wir erzählen das Geschehen und
seine Konsequenzen zu Ende in Teil 2
dieser Episode danke fürs Zuhören
erstmal euer Stefan und euer
MCO dir hat diese Folge von tout
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Reusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland